clinical trials are necessary to improve
and develop new medicine to combat
disease but in recent years they've been
on a steady decline in europe too much
bureaucracy and expense has forced
companies to decamp to foreign countries
but new rules are set to revitalize the
market and one of the big changes is
increased accountability we'll get a
summary of all results whether they're
positive or negative
which will be public accessible and we
will also have clinical study reports
of all of those trials that are going
for authorization of medicines so that's
a huge step forward
help for those trying to stub out the
habit by an overhaul of tobacco laws
with 700 000 deaths a year in europe
much more needed to be done
the health committee has rubber stamped
a deal that will ensure 65 of packaging
to carry a health warning and the
flavored and menthol cigarettes be
phased out as well as regulation of
e-cigarettes for the first time the
draft law will go for final mep approval
at the plenary in february or early
march with a new directive coming into
force in 2016
it's not always the most expensive
object that holds the greatest value
whether it's a private painting
religious statue or even an
archaeological finding repatriation of
valuable or cultural artifacts have been
going on for decades but in the last 20
years there have been just 60
repatriations
the new rules could help facilitate the
process between member states
positions
the favor is the mechanism of the
cooperation administrative and foreign